Ahora que tenemos un conocimiento básico
acerca de las razones
tratemos de resolver
problemas más complejos.
Tenemos un salón de clases con 55 estudiantes
y sabemos también
que la razón...
la razón
de niños...
de niños
a niñas,
lo indico de esta manera
es de 4 a 7
y lo que quiero saber es,
¿cuántas niñas...
cuántas
niñas
tengo que agregar...
o podría ponerlo,
necesito...
necesito
agregar
para...
necesito agregar
para que la razón
sea...
necesito agregar para que la razón sea
de
a 2?
Y seguimos considerando que ésta
es la razón de niños a niñas,
no se ha invertido
esto para nada.
Actualmente la razón es de
4 niños por cada 7 niñas
y lo que quiero hacer agregar algunas
niñas para que la razón se de 1 niño cada
2 niñas,
¿cómo hacemos esto?
Bien, si recordamos
el primero video sobre razones,
conocemos que hay 55 estudiantes
y sabemos que
la razón es de 4 a 7,
quizás nos ayude saber
cuantos niños y niñas hay actualmente.
Así que la razón actual
es de 4 a 7,
la razón de niños
a niñas
actualmente
es de 4
a 7,
eso significa
si sumamos estas dos,
si sumamos estas dos tenemos que
por cada...
por cada
estudiantes...
11 estudiantes ...
por cada 11 estudiantes
tenemos 4 niños y
7 niñas.
Hay
4 niños...
4 niños y
niñas,
eso es lo que nos da esta razón.
Si este salón de 55 estudiantes
lo dividimos
en grupos de 11 estudiantes,
en cada uno de ellos
va a haber
4 niños
y 7 niñas,
eso es lo que nos da esta razón,
si separamos en grupos homegéneos
de 11 estudiantes,
vamos a obtener siempre
4 niños
y 7 niñas.
Ahora,
¿cuántos grupos de
11 estudiantes hay?
Bueno,
si tenemos 55
estudiantes
y queremos dividirlos
en grupos de 11 estudiantes,
es decir 55 estudiantes y queremos repartirlos
en 11
grupos,
más bien, queremos dividirlos
en grupos de 11 estudiantes,
entre 11
estudiantes
por grupo,
así es que 55 estudiantes divididos
en grupos de 11 estudiantes,
¿cuánto nos va a dar?
Nos va dar
55 entre 11, 5 grupos...
5 grupos
de 11
estudiantes.
Y como ya sabemos,
cada grupo tiene 4 niños
y 7 niñas,
de tal manera que
en cada uno de estos 5 grupos hay
4 niños,
por lo cual hay en total
por 4 igual a
20 niños
y 7 niñas en cada uno de los 5 grupos,
es decir, en total 5 por 7
que es igual a
niñas...
35 niñas.
Y todo cuadra,
20 más 35
es igual a 55
y la razón de 20 a 35
es la misma razón de 4 a 7,
nuestros cálculos son correctos.
Eso es lo que tenemos actualmente
y lo que queremos
es aumentar el número de niñas en el salón
para cambiar la razón,
hagamos eso.
Así es que actualmente tenemos
20 niños
y 35 niñas,
es el número que calculamos
de niños y niñas que tenemos en el salón
y queremos agregar
un número "x" de niñas
a ese salón...
y queremos agregar "
x" niñas al salón
para que la razón de niños a niñas
sea ahora
de 1 a 2.
Tenemos ahora una ecuación
con una incógnita que hay que resolver.
Aunque esta ecuación
la podemos resolver mentalmente,
¿20 es a qué número como 1 es a 2?
Más fácil,
si 1
es la mitad de 2,
entonces 20 es la mitad de 40,
así es que esto
tiene que ser 40
con lo cual "x" tiene
que ser igual a 5.
Bueno y si no lo quieres hacer mentalmente
lo podemos hacer algebraicamente,
podemos hacer la multiplicación
cruzada de los denominadores,
35 por "x" más 1 e
s igual a 35 más "x"
y esto es igual a
2 por 20 = 40,
que es el resultado
que obtuvimos mentalmente cuando razonamos
que 35 más "x"
tiene que ser igual a 40,
así es que restando 35 a ambos lados obtenemos que "x" es igual a 5,
por lo que
al agregar 5 niñas al salón
vamos a tener en total
40 niñas
y al tener 20 niños,
la razón va a ser
de 20 a 40
ó 2 a 4
ó lo que es lo mismo, 1 a 2.
Y así hemos concluido.